>> Anya Creightney: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I think I'm on.
Okay. We're going to dive in.
I'm told we're a
little behind time.
So I hope you're all enjoying
the 2018 National Book Festival.
It's certainly a day
-- yes, please applaud.
[ Applause ]
It's certainly a day full of fun
and exploration and learning,
or at least I always think so.
My name is Anya Creightney.
I'm the Programs Manager in the
Poetry and Literature Center
which is housed in the
Library of Congress.
The Poetry and Literary Center
is many things, but the thing
that you may know about
us is we're the home
of the U.S. Poet Laureate.
So today is particularly
auspicious because I'm joined
by not one, but two Poet
Laureates here on stage,
Miss Tracy K. Smith
and Mr. Robert Hass.
Welcome to you both.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Anya Creightney: So just
so we get the formality
out of the way, I'll read
a brief bio for you both.
Robert Hass was born in
San Francisco, California.
He is the author of nine poetry
collections including Field
Guide, Praise, Sun Under
Wood, Time and Materials,
Poems 1997 through 2005."
And his newest collected,
Apple Trees at Olema .
He is a Pulitzer Prize
and National Book Award
winner, among many others.
Bob Hass served as U.S. Poet
Laureate from 1995 to 1997.
He's turning off his
phone [laughter].
Tracy K. Smith was born in
Falmouth, Massachusetts,
and raised in Fairfield,
California.
She's the author of four books
of poetry including Wade
in the Water, Life on Mars ,
winner of the Pulitzer Prize,
Duende, and The
Body's Question .
She's also the author of a
memoir, Ordinary Light ,
finalist for the 2015
National Book Award.
Tracy was reappointed U.S. Poet
Laureate in March of this year
by our current Librarian of
Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden.
So, again, please, one big
round of applause for our pair.
[ Applause ]
So we're here today to discuss
their recent respective books.
Tracy's Book, American
Journal .
I'll hold up this show-and-tell.
American Journal, 50 Poems
For Our Time is an anthology
co-published by the Library
of Congress and Greywolf Press.
Tracy, you both selected
the poems
and wrote the introduction
for this book.
And, Bob, your book, A Little
Book on Form, An Exploration
Into the Formal
Imagination of Poetry .
Maybe even -- no not quite up
there, but any rate, here it is.
And I think of the book
as a sort of deep dive
into the history of poetry,
but also the inclinations
that get us to write
poems in the first place.
So I wonder, Tracey,
if you'll kick us off
and maybe start with a poem.
It's as good a place as any.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Oh, yeah.
What a great idea.
>> Anya Creightney:
Perhaps you could read
from American Journal ,
and "A Poem by Ivy
Frances," on page 418.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Sure.
>> Anya Creightney: Do you
want to -- can borrow my book.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Okay.
"Sugar and Brine,
Ella's Understanding."
Daddy slaughtered the hog
right there in the side yard,
and it hurt to see it.
But that won't stop
me from eating.
Come Thanksgiving,
I'll dip a bit of ham
in Jackson's ribbon cane syrup
and pop it inside a biscuit.
When it's time to
celebrate, something dies.
When something dies, we
take it with the sweet.
Take my cousin, Gerald.
He left us last summer
-- a tractor accident.
We were cousins by marriage,
but friends by choice.
So I cried more than when I
broke my leg jumping off the
front porch, bone
snapped clean through.
After the funeral, as
the Lord is my witness,
those were the best
potato pies I ever had.
Yesterday, the yellow
pines meet the creek,
that boy on the other side
of the property line helped
bring his daddy's cattle in.
I watched him watch me
standing in a field littered
with cow's corn, my
head tilted just enough
to let him know I was curious.
He left a scarlet ribbon
tied to the barbed wire.
My heart skipped quicker than
a swallow's when I found it.
Now I'm wondering that
throat's going to open.
I need to warn him.
The wheel never rests,
never stops
>> Anya Creightney: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Tracy K. Smith: Ivy Frances.
>> Anya Creightney:
So I chose --
that is a leaping-off point
for a couple of reasons.
One I think the poem so
beautifully captured the voice
of a child, first and foremost.
And it also does this thing
with cognitive dissonance
that we all can recognize.
You know, loving and, you know,
attracted to something that,
you know, either dies, an
animal that is then killed,
so on and so forth, right?
And I love the ending.
And so the warning, that sort
of harbinger at the end, right?
It certainly has a presence.
But I also chose it
because the poem is,
in a way, easy to penetrate.
And I know that the
poems that you chose
for this book were intentional.
And so I wonder if you
can talk a little bit
about the assemblage of the
book and what you were trying
to capture with the project.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Sure.
I agree with you
about, by these poem,
I think that it's
beautiful, it's direct,
the vocabulary is
clear and familiar,
and it touches upon
feelings that are troubling,
that are sort of subterranean,
and it captures a moment
of a dawning awareness
from a child's perspective.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Tracy K. Smith: I wanted
to find or celebrate poems
that allowed you to have
an immediate experience.
I think all poems are
doing a lot of work
to facilitate an immediate
sense of connection
between the reader
and the speaker.
This anthology is an
offering, as I see it,
to people who love poetry
and might want to think
about how poems can
show us different things
about ourselves, about life in
this country, about language.
But I also wanted it to
be an offering for someone
who might have a little bit
of anxiety or apprehension,
having perhaps been told
that one must have a vigorous
vocabulary of literary terms
and knowledge of literary
history, that reading poetry is
about sleuthing something out.
I wanted to put all of
that to rest for somebody
and say you can read this
poem, hear it speak to you,
feel certain visceral feelings
activated without needing
to name the poetic devices.
So I hope it's a book
that will bring poetry
to immediate life for a reader.
>> Anya Creightney: Mm-hmm.
It certainly did for me.
Well, you mentioned
life in this country.
And in the introduction
you tell us that the title
of the whole thing is borrowed
from a Robert Hayden poem.
Robert Hayden, of course,
was the first African
American U.S. Poet Laureate.
So I thought a nice
homage there.
But the poem itself if about
an alien whose from outer space
and comes down to
Earth and he's short
of describing what
it is he sees.
And he's both, you
know, attracted,
but he's also repelled
and, at times, confused.
And so in a way it made me
think a little bit about poetry.
And I think -- do you
think it's poetry's job
to both describe what it is that
we're inherently attracted to
and can it also relieve
what we're repelled by?
Can it do that work or
should it do that work?
>> Tracy K. Smith: Well,
I definitely turn to poems
for the difficult and sometimes
dark feelings that I live with,
the questions that
point me in directions
that aren't necessarily
celebratory, even while I also,
of course, understand
that poetry is great
at bringing a sense
of wonder and joy
and hope into new language.
Yeah, I think that whatever the
topic, what poems are doing,
and this came up at the
end of the last session,
I think it's bring --
poems are bringing language
and sometimes unlikely language
to bear upon the feelings
that are deep within us,
the things that we live
with without necessarily
talking about --
>> Anya Creightney: Right.
>> Tracy K. Smith: -- the things
that confound us sometimes.
Poems do a lot of work
to bring the right terms
to bear upon that.
And I think it's exciting
when the terms are not
literal or direct, you know.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Poems are not
trying to translate something
in literal terms, but to
say feeling is so strange.
We've got to do some - we've
got to go to the wrong context
to get the right feelings.
>> Anya Creightney: I know.
>> Tracy K. Smith: And I
find a great relief in that.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Tracy K. Smith: This is
an anthology that has gone
through in celebration of things
and poems that are maybe going
to be useful for the things
that we live that are heavy,
that are, you know, difficult
to share even with one's self.
>> Anya Creightney:
Yeah, I agree.
It sounds like you're
describing the act of trying
to transmogrify private
language and make it a human --
or share it with another human
which I think is really special.
Would you read another
poem from the book?
>> Tracy K. Smith: Oh, yeah.
>> Anya Creightney:
A poem by Ross Gay.
Okay. Give the title.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Okay.
This is Ross Gay's
"Becoming a Horse."
It was dragging my hands along
its belly, loosing the bit
and wiping the spit from its
mouth that made me a snatch
of grass in the thing's
maw, a fly tasting its ear.
It was touching my nose to his
made me know the clover's bloom,
my wet eye to his made me
know the long field's secrets.
But it was putting my
heart to the horse's
that made me know
the sorrow of horses,
the sorrow of a brook
creasing a field,
the maggot turning
in its corpse.
Made me forsake my thumbs for
the sheen of unshod hooves.
And in this way drop my torches.
And in this way drop my knives.
Feel the small song
in my chest swell
and my coat glisten and twitch.
And my face grow long.
And these words cast
off, at last,
for the slow honest
tongue of horses.
In some ways this poem kind
of enacts what you're
talking about.
>> Anya Creightney:
You're picking
up what I'm saying [inaudible].
>> Tracy K. Smith: Yeah.
You know, this poem offers
us a recourse to feelings
that sit outside of language and
also a sense of unlikely empathy
or connection, right, between
the human and the horse.
And it's not bringing the
horse into human terms.
It's finding a place that
literally embodied by the horse
that allows the speaker to
feel something that's larger
and stranger than
what is ordinary.
I love the things
that he discovers.
The sorrow of horses.
The sorrow of a brook
creasing a field.
That's not the immediate feeling
I would get, but, you know,
he's guiding me to recognize
a sense of, you know,
maybe mortality or finitude
from a perspective
that's outside of a human.
I like that, you know, the poem
begins by saying it was this
that gave me that, it was
this that gave me that,
but then there's a way toward
the bottom of the poem,
a sentence begins, feel
the small song in my chest.
This could just be a colloquial
way of extending it was this
that made me feel that.
But it also, by that
point in the poem,
feels like a command
to the reader --
>> Anya Creightney: Absolutely.
>> Tracy K. Smith: -- feel the
small song in my chest swell
and my coat glisten and twitch.
And so reading the poem I'm
also invited into the, you know,
the point of view and
the perspective that's --
of the great beast.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
That said so capably.
And you were thinking along on
the same lines I was thinking.
The lines for me, and in
this way drop my torches
and in this way drop my knives,
feel the small song in my chest.
That small song can
be poetry, right?
Even the way you read it, you
pause and it was pleasurable
to hear how you read
those lines.
It really made me -- it seemed
as if it enacted what it
is you're attempting to do
with your [inaudible] project.
And so I know this is
a companion essentially
to your project, travelling
the country, rural countries --
excuse me, rural
communities, in fact.
So maybe you want to
tell us a little bit
about your Poet Laureate
Project, where you've been.
I know you're just
freshly back from Alaska.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Yeah.
>> Anya Creightney: As fresh
as yesterday, all of yesterday.
So tell -- share with
the audience a little bit
about how it's been and who
you've seen in the travels.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Oh, yeah.
It's been such a gift.
So the project is now called
American Conversations,
Celebrating Poetry
in Rural communities.
And that's really
what it's been.
We've taken trips to different
small rural communities
in different parts
of the country.
The states that we've
visited so far are New Mexico,
South Carolina, Kentucky,
and Alaska.
And in each state we visited
different communities,
either libraries and community
centers or more curated spaces
like rehab facilities,
retirement centers,
and talked with people of --
large and small groups of people
about what they hear,
what they're reminded of,
what they're made to want to say
back to the palms that we read.
So this -- now that this book
is in print, it feels almost
like a -- I said this -- it
feels to me like a hymnal
or something, when having
grown up going to church.
We have something that
we can open together,
read the poems together,
and then say,
okay, what do you notice?
Where can we go from here?
My wish has been to get to a
place that's not small talk
as an outsider in a community
where many people
know each other.
I want to talk about
what's real.
And I think a great way
of leaping into that is
to have the vehicle of
the poem to say, oh,
I hear my mother's
voice in this poem.
I'm thinking in the Ivy
Frances poem about when I began
to recognize what loss was.
This is how that happened.
And so suddenly the poems
are allowing us to open
up different interior
spaces and it's exciting
to me that, a, that happens.
It's not just a wish.
That the conversations
about poems are not really
that different from place
to place, and that readers,
no matter who they are,
when they listen willingly
and carefully to a poem,
they make it useful
for where and who they are.
So a poem that is
ostensibly about family
or about love can be useful
to someone who's wrestling
with questions of
addiction, can be useful
to someone who's dealing
with loss, in the same way
that when we look at abstract,
you know, designs, we often,
as humans, see human faces.
I think a poem does --
invites the same kind
of involuntary work in a
reader, and that's been --
it's been exciting to
learn different things
about poems that I like.
>> Anya Creightney: So it sounds
like people have dropped their
torches and their knives --
>> Tracy K. Smith: Yeah.
>> Anya Creightney: --
and had a conversation.
So how have the trips
affected you
and your learning
about yourself?
You're talking a lot about how
[inaudible] we can be a vessel
to have a conversation
with others.
But has it changed your
conversation with yourself?
>> Tracy K. Smith: Well, yeah.
I feel - I love the
feelings that I get.
There was something so
beautiful about visiting --
in Alaska we visited a Veterans
and Pioneers Retirement Center
because there are many
people who were part
of the Homesteading Movement in
Alaska who came and, you know,
cleared or worked the land
for a period of years.
And now they've retired
with the sponsorship,
I guess, of the state.
So there were people that
were speaking actively.
But there were many people in
the room that were not verbal.
There were people who were, you
know, living with Alzheimer's.
And to be in a gathering where
speech wasn't the main thing
that was happening, where poetry
was allowing something else
to enter the room -- a lot of
people use the word humbled,
but it was humbling in
a really beautiful way
to realize something's
happening,
and it's not going
to announce itself.
I have a lot to think about.
I feel sort of gifted by
the different reactions
and the fearlessness of
people in coming into a space
where maybe they're not as
used to thinking and talking
about poems, but being willing
to let something happen.
And, of course, I've seen some
really incredibly beautiful
parts of the country.
And I've gotten a little
glimpse or even description
about what life there is
driven by or characterized by.
>> Anya Creightney:
That sounds beautiful.
Bob, I want to bring you
into the conversation.
Does all this talk about
laureateship bring you back
to your two terms as
U.S. Poet Laureate?
>> Robert Hass: Yes.
>> Anya Creightney:
Yes Good short answer.
And anything else?
What does it call up for you
as you're hearing Tracy
describe this unique time
in very few people's lives
to be the U.S. Poet Laureate?
>> Robert Hass: Well,
the job is odd.
Yes. We were talking
about it beforehand,
that you're given this title
and you suddenly get a whole
bunch of projections --
>> Anya Creightney: Right.
>> Robert Hass: -- that
you didn't get before.
I've been going around
the country.
We -- poets of our
generations did reading poems.
But then you're called Poet
Laureate and someone comes
up after the reading and
say, would you hold my baby
so I could take a
picture of you?
That hadn't happened
before [laughter].
So there was that experience.
And the puzzle of what
to do with this --
to talk to the world about
this art we love, you know?
Trying to weigh -- to
take whatever shine comes
with the title and
shine it back on people.
I thought about spending
a week in this --
in the middle of winter in
the school in Chicago run
by Catholic nuns for --
everybody's been kicked
out of every other school.
When I got the job of being Poet
Laureate I thought, oh my god,
what do I wear, you know?
>> Anya Creightney: Right.
The practical questions.
>> Robert Hass: Thoreau thing.
Beware anything that
requires new clothes.
But I bought one of those --
I brought one of those
heavy black overcoats
that Congressional
Aids wear on the Metro.
And I put it on and
I was in Chicago
and there was a young woman
in the audience just
kind of looking at me.
And I was blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
And I -- it was unnerving,
her gaze.
And I said, Gloria,
what are you thinking?
And she said, I'm thinking
your world/my world.
So you learn --
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Robert Hass: -- learn
things from our experience.
A school in Houston,
not far from George
and Barbara Bush's house,
where most of the students --
it's the school named
after Longfellow --
are Salvadorian refugees
being taught
by a very dedicated African
American teacher who --
trying to figure out how
to include the parents
who are mostly illiterate
into the conversation --
started a garden of native
plants and of vegetables
because that was what the
parents were really good at.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Mm-hmm.
>> Robert Hass: And I
got to spend afternoon --
this was funded by
Shell in Houston.
I got -- Shell Oil.
>> Anya Creightney: Surprising.
>> Robert Hass: About which
I have complicated feelings.
>> Anya Creightney: Yes,
I imagine [laughter].
>> Robert Hass: But
she had figured a way
to make the kids proud
of their parents --
>> Anya Creightney:
Mm, that's lovely.
>> Robert Hass: --
while teaching them
what healthy eating is,
and how to do things
with their hands.
Anyway, it was a great
gift in that way to have
so many experiences that I never
would have had anywhere else.
>> Anya Creightney:
That's beautiful.
You mentioned school-age
children in this beautiful scene
that you're describing
here in Houston.
Your Poet Laureate
Project, River of Words,
was really for children,
was from kindergarten all
the way up until 12th grade.
>> Robert Hass: Mm-hmm.
>> Anya Creightney: That does
that bring up for you now?
It was a project.
Maybe you can describe
what it was.
>> Robert Hass: Well,
River of Words was just --
was a project to just try to
get into the schools every year
for children occasioned to
make art and to write poems
about their immediate
environment, whatever it was.
And at that time, for example,
in schools of education
there were no programs
about environmental education.
That's changed since.
So at the time we started
to do that, to get the --
and the program continues today.
There are thousands
of school kids who get
out their art supplies
or get out their paper
and pen and wrote poems.
So I think it was a
useful thing to do.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Robert Hass: Yeah.
>> Anya Creightney:
Especially since it continued.
Well, you know, it's funny.
In the previous event
just before this one,
I think it was Patricia
Lockwood or someone was talking
about time being nonlinear.
And so in preparation for this
conversation, I listened back
to your inauguration
as U.S. Poet Laureate.
And you closed the whole reading
with a somewhat unusual poem
called "Shame, An Aria."
And I was so moved.
I mean, it's not -- it's
not a conical Bob Hass poem.
I really don't think
of it that way.
But I was so moved.
And I wonder if you would read
it for everyone if -- and if --
you can say no and
read something that --
>> Robert Hass: No, I
would be happy to read it.
>> Anya Creightney: Okay.
Thank you.
>> Robert Hass: But --
>> Anya Creightney: This
is quite a pleasure for me.
>> Robert Hass: --
poems that follow you
around like some embarassing
pet animal [laughter]
when -- this is one of them.
My students say, are you going
to read your nose-picking
poem [laughter]?
Just so I give you a
clue to what it's about.
This is "Shame, An Aria."
You think you've grown
up in various ways
and then the elevator door opens
and you're standing inside
reaming out your nose --
something about the dry
air in the mountains --
and find yourself facing two
spruce elderly couples dressed
like improbable wildflowers in
their primary color definitely
on vacation sports outfits,
a wormy color of one
of the body's shameful and
congealed lubricants gleaming
on your fingertip under
the fluorescent lights,
and there really
isn't too much to say
as you descend the remaining two
flights with them in silence,
all five of you staring
straight ahead
in this commodious aluminum
group coffin toward the
ground floor.
You are, of course, trying to
think of something witty to say.
Your hand is, of course, in your
pocket discreetly transferring
the offending article into
its accumulation of lint.
One man clears his throat
and you admit to yourself
that there are kinds of people
-- not people in particular --
you hate, that these are they,
and that your mind is
nevertheless working
like a demented cicada
drying its wings after rain
to find some way to save
yourself in your craven,
small child's large
ego's idea of their eyes.
You even crank it up a notch,
getting more high-minded
and lugubrious in
the seconds it takes
for the almost silent
gears and oiled hydraulic
or pneumatic plungers and cables
of the machine to set you down.
"Nose picking," you imagine
explaining to the upturned,
reverential faces, "is
in a way the ground floor
of being [laughter].
The body's fluids and solids,
its various despised disjecta,
toenail parings left
absently on the bedside table
that your lover the next
night notices there,
streaks in underwear or little,
faint, odorous pee-blossoms
of the palest polleny color,
the stiffened small droplets
in the sheets of the body's
shuddering late night loneliness
and selflove, russets of
menstrual blood, toe-jam,
earwax, phlegm, the
little dead militias
of white corpuscles we call
pus, what are they after all
but the twins of the
juices of mortal glory --
sap, wine, breast
milk, sperm, and blood.
The most intimate hygienes,
those deepest tribal rules
that teach a child trying to
struggle up out of the fear
of loss of love from anger,
hatred, fear, they get taught
to us, don't they, as
boundaries, terrible thresholds,
what can be said, or thought,
or done, inside the house
but not out, what can be
said, or thought, or done,
only by oneself, which must
therefore best not be done
at all, so that the core of
the self, we learn early,
is where shame lives and where
we also learn doubleness,
a certain practical cunning,
and what a theater is,
and the ability to lie -- the
elevator has opened and closed,
the silver-haired columbines
of the mountain are murmuring
over breakfast menus
in the room full
of bright plastics
somewhere, and you,
grown up in various ways,
are at a typewriter,
thinking of all the slimes
and jellies of decay,
thinking that the zombie
passages, ghoul corridors,
radiant death's-head entries to
that realm of terror claim us
in the sick, middle of the
night sessions of self-hatred
and remorse, in the day's
most hidden, watchful self,
the man not farting in
the line at the bank,
no trace of discomfort on his
mild, neighbor-loving face,
the woman calculating
the distance
to the next person she
can borrow a tampon
from while she smiles
attentively
into this new man's
explanation of his theory
about deforestation, claims us
also, by seepage, in our lies,
small malices, razor knicks
on the skins of others
of our meannesses, deprivations,
rage, and what to do but face
that way and praise the kingdom
of the dead, praise the power
which we have all kinds of
phrases to elide the fact
that none of us can
worm our way out of --
"that no man can evade," "which
all must kneel to in the end" --
praise it by calling it time,
say it is master of the seasons,
mistress of the moment of the
hunting hawk's sudden sheen
of grape-brown gleaming
in the morning sun,
the characteristic slow gesture,
two fingers across the
cheekbone deliberately,
of the lover dreamily oiling her
skin, in this moment, no other,
before she turns to you the
face she wants you to see
and the rest that she hopes,
when she can't keep it hidden,
you can somehow love and which,
if you could love
yourself, you would.
[ Applause ]
>> Anya Creightney: Thank
you for your indulgence.
That was quite a treat to
hear you read that poem.
I love it for many reasons, but
one, it's funny, as we all hear.
It's a bit strange.
But also it takes
us in these flights
of fancy we would never
expect and ends with, I think,
something very human which
is this idea of boundary
and shame being -- keeping us
from ourselves and from loving
and truly understanding
one another
and how it is a learned
intrinsic behavior
from when you're young.
And how we got to confront it
ultimately and get rid of it.
Am I understanding correctly?
>> Robert Hass: Yeah.
>> Anya Creightney: Okay,
good [laughter], good.
My close read is accurate.
Well, thank you for
sharing with us.
That was an absolute pleasure.
Let's turn to a little
book on form.
It's a reference
text, but it's unique
in its being a reference text.
I think of it as
almost like a notebook,
notes toward describing form.
Maybe you can talk a little
bit about its assemblage
and the inclination
to write the book.
>> Robert Hass: That book
happened in a funny way
because I was invited to
be a Visiting Professor --
actually, my wife was invited
to be a Visiting Professor
of Poetry at the Iowa
Writers' Workshop.
And I came along, and they said,
would you teach a
course on form in poetry?
And so I looked at books on
form in poetry and they were all
about hour you make a
sonnet and how you --
and most people don't go around
making sonnets anymore --
>> Anya Creightney:
Right, right.
>> Robert Hass: -- that
they don't do anymore.
So I was thinking, well,
how would you go about this?
And I was thinking about little
formal things, the way --
what makes poetry memorable --
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Robert Hass: -- which is --
and so I did handouts for the
class on what makes one line
and what makes two lines
related to each other,
and what makes three lines.
And I was having fun churning
out these weekly
readings for the students.
And that was that.
And then about 10 years later
my editor wrote to me and said,
what's this book
you wrote on form?
And I said, I don't know
what you're talking about.
And it turns out
some of my students
from this class had
been using these --
>> Anya Creightney: The notes.
>> Robert Haas: --
things online.
And my editor said,
they're really interesting,
we should do a little
book of them.
And I thought, a free
book, you know [laughter].
A book on form.
So then I started adding to it.
And we had already
definitely decided it was going
to be called A Little
Book on Form .
And now it's a tone [inaudible].
But that was how it got started.
I was interested in the
way that evolution --
evolution of poetry I think
in every language happened
because it was the oldest
memory storage technology,
was saying things rhythmically.
So in Serbian and Chinese and
Bantu and every language people
over 200,000 years or however
long human beings have been
making speech, have been
evolving the most memorable ways
to say things, at
the core of poetry.
And in the ancient poetry, of
course, the epics all being
by evoking the goddess
of memory because of --
so I was interested
in what it --
what kinds of patterning
made things memorable.
So that -- and then I
thought, what is the difference
between grief poems
and praise poems.
Do they have different
rhythmic patterning?
So I wanted to go back
as far as I could.
So -- which for us as the
inventorying is literacy
in these different languages.
And if you look across the
room, all the earliest poems
that got written
down are prayers --
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Yeah.
>> Robert Haas: -- in
one way or another.
And they have particular
rhythmic patterns.
And so anyway, it was incredible
fun to be suddenly trying
to explore and give
examples of reading
from that sense of the art.
>> Anya Creightney:
It was fun to read.
It's unlike what many reference
texts I've read in terms
of form, which is
to say something what
you're describing, Tracy,
that does poetry a disservice,
which is to say, you know,
a sonnet is this and -- or this
particular metrical pattern
makes X, Y, Z poem
successful, so on and so forth.
Instead, as you're describing,
it seems like you
were interested
in what I think you call these
were the sensual gestures.
>> Robert Haas: Yeah.
>> Anya Creightney: And its
relationship to imagination.
Can you talk about
imagination and how
that also is part of
the whole mixture?
>> Robert Haas: When I was
thinking about this, my daughter
and her kids were with us
for a period in the summer,
and my grandson got up in the
morning and sat on my lap,
and we read the comics
for a bit.
And then said, "Grandpa," he
spoke quite early, but he said,
"Grandpa, if when my folks
get up they want to go
to the bakery, you can come."
And I thought, form and desire.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Yeah.
>> Robert Haas: [Laughter]
He's already figured
out a conditional, and
he's figure out how
to use it to get to sugar.
>> Anya Creightney: To getting
what he wants [laughter].
It's powerful.
>> Robert Haas: I thought --
that's what I've been
after [laughter].
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
That's great.
So tell us a little bit
about how understanding the
imaginative playground makes us
a better reader,
or a better writer.
And Tracy, fell free to
answer that question too.
Either of you.
>> Robert Haas: What
would you say, Tracy?
>> Tracy K. Smith: Well, I would
say that I'm always interested
in why it would be --
it would make sense
to turn to a particular form.
What does the particular
form feel
like it could be an
adequate container for,
and what can it teach
me about the feelings
that want to get addressed.
And so instead of
thinking what --
I'm trying to find a path
into the inside of the form
that can give shape and courage
to my if/then constructions.
And that's what I ask my
students to think about, too,
why would you write a sonnet,
what could it help you to do.
And I'm asking for
real because I want
to know the answer
to the question.
I say, well, I guess if I
want to think about, you know,
investing in something and
then finding my way through it
to something different, a
counterintuitive take on it,
then I might use that form.
And then it becomes -- form
becomes about vocabulary
for grief or desire
or, you know,
whatever other feeling emerges.
>> Robert Haas: I think another
thing that we have in common is
that with -- in your
[inaudible] poetry
and with modernism
we inherited the idea
that all the traditional holding
forms are no longer adequate.
That they have to be reinvented
across the whole range
of early 20th Century poets who
are -- where for us, I think,
it was certainly for my
generation, still totally alive
as models and possibilities.
So there's also the injunction
to re-imagine what those shapes,
shape of grief, shape
of [inaudible] anger,
shape of desire are,
and how to use them.
I was thinking, listening
, Ross's poem is gorgeous
and in one way is a
completely traditional song.
It's written in the
first person.
It narrates an experience.
In the last lines it tells you
the meaning of the experience.
You can kind of pick
out the beginning
of that kind of poem
in the 1790s.
[Inaudible] goes out into the
woods and has an experience.
The [inaudible] goes out and has
a significant experience poem is
the very form of song
that we've inherited.
And you can work in it
as he does in this one,
and do gorgeous things.
And a lot of poets
are trying to do --
you can break it up
and try to figure
out what's next after that.
And that work of imagination
for a writer is figuring out how
to get out beyond
your comfort zone.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Yeah.
>> Robert Haas: Which in my
experience is often a disaster,
you know [laughter].
Oh, okay, you can't -- but
you have to keep trying
or life will make you try.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Yeah.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
I've been told more than once
that you can't do anything
in a poem that you
couldn't do yourself, right?
And it seems similar to
what you're describing,
that it's an attempt to keep
going and to keep pushing,
and to keep pushing
past one's boundary.
Does that seem accurate to you?
>> Robert Haas: From my
experience of translating,
I spent 25 years helping my
neighbor, Czeslaw Milosz,
the great Polish poet, turn his
poems into English, and so I got
to watch this 30, 40 year body
of poetry was it
evolved and changed.
And also from other poets that
I've studied, where you just --
either because I've agreed
to write something or just
because I love them and
want to understand them.
You get to see that every
poet has a certain range
of modes they can use to get
at what they're getting at.
And it's made me less
uncomfortable with the fact
that I'm -- there are certain
ways I go about things.
>> Anya Creightney:
You have a mode?
>> Robert Haas: I don't know if
you ever had a feeling like, oh,
no, I'm writing another
Tracy Smith poem?
Have you?
>> Tracy K. Smith:
Oh yeah [laughter].
Yeah. And then you find,
you know, the gradations
that the self can see
are -- there's so much --
they seem vast, but then what
the outside world can see,
it's just a millimeter
of difference.
But to feel the -- to feel
emboldened by what seems
like a giant step within
your own lexicon is enough
to keep going, I think.
>> Anya Creightney: It
seems like we're talking
around living, you know, a
thoughtful, engaging life.
And I wonder what you think --
how poetry helps us do that.
How does it instruct
us in that way?
>> Tracy K. Smith:
Well, I think that --
I always feel like as a
writer, but also as a reader,
you get to go that
best self place.
And then you come back down
from it and you see, okay,
but I still yell at people,
I still I get upset --
>> Anya Creightney: Right.
I still pick my nose --
>> Tracy K. Smith: -- but
language is so beautiful
because it -- if you let it,
it can lead you beyond
what is obvious.
It can lead you beyond
what you think is true,
into something that's
more deeply true.
It's a -- it's almost like
a laboratory for moving
around to different
perspectives.
It certainly urges to listen
to things outside of yourself,
even if you think it's your own
voice that you're channeling.
All of that I think is in
service of being a better self,
being more alive to other
people, and other things
that aren't people in the world.
And maybe even more
submissive toward them,
which I think is important.
>> Robert Haas: At least
that's the renaissance, anyway,
in Europe, that's exactly
what poetry has been for,
is for the self talking to
the self, the part of you
that wakes you up to your life.
And that's in a way the
job of a poet, then,
that I didn't quite know
when I started, is the job is
to stay awake, pretty much,
so that you're available
to this experience of -- I think
of a bookshelf my daughter,
I don't know if she
was here, when she was
in high school she was
babysitting at someone's house,
and I brought over her
books because she had forgot
to bring them to
do her homework.
And she said, do you notice
anything about this house?
And I said, what?
And she said, there's no TV,
they're readers [laughter].
And I went and looked at the
bookshelf and you could tell
that there was -- one of them
was probably a psychotherapist,
and one of them maybe was
a medical administrator
or something, and there were --
I saw what novels there were,
and what history books.
One of them liked to read
English detective stories.
One of them read
self-help books.
And there were a
few books of poetry.
Sylvia Plath, Langston
Hughes, Auden,
Ferlinghetti was a
[inaudible] area.
And I thought, that's
about right.
These are busy people with busy
lives, and they're not like me,
reading poetry all the time,
but what poetry is form
in their life is that place
where you wake up to yourself.
You know? To say, what
the hell is going on here,
when the noise stops
for a minute.
>> Tracy K. Smith:
Oh, I love that.
>> Anya Creightney:
Yeah, that's nice.
And it's no small task
to continue to do it.
Well, you mention -- well,
it's funny you're comment
about there not being in a TV
in this house makes me think,
is there something
that poetry can do
that other art forms cannot?
That you think that poetry is
best suited to do this thing
or maybe multiple
things, I don't know.
>> Tracy K. Smith:
Well, I think that --
I mean, a lot of what I value
in poetry lives in other forms.
I like the way that poetry
allows us to stop time,
turn it backwards,
open things up.
Language does that.
Film does that.
But when you're reading
a poem it's just you
and the speaker doing --
on this journey together.
I don't know, what else?
There's more, but I'm
curious about you would say.
>> Robert Haas: I think
it can do a lot of --
I think it can do some
things that film can do.
Song is a separate art, is
complicated from poetry.
Fiction. The thing that poetry
can specifically do is --
that belongs to it as an art,
is that it comes
from the inner voice.
And it shapes it around things
you've thought and felt.
And it's more intimate art than
any of the others in that way.
And the places where
-- I think about myself
as a 17 year old
kid in the basement
of City Lights bookstore,
opening books of poems
and seeing people saying things
I didn't know you could say.
It introduced me to
myself in a certain way,
and I think that's still
the deepest power of poetry.
The kind of oral poetry
that was being described
in the last panel, that has to
do with communal experience.
>> Tracy K. Smith: Yeah,
that's what I was going to add.
>> Robert Haas: It has to do
with bringing a bunch
of people together.
And it's great, and I
love that kind of writing.
And in a way my blah, blah,
blah [inaudible] is
that kind of poem.
It can be performed.
But the poetry that I love
the most is the self-talking,
the most intimate way to other
people's most intimate selves.
>> Tracy K. Smith: I
feel like that even
that private lyric moment
that shapes so much poetry,
it's a living in the
same way that, you know,
the Bible is supposed
to be, a living word.
I really do believe that
poetry is animating language
to a place that's
-- that is capable
of creating a sense
of community.
I feel that when I'm
in a group of people
and we are listening
together in wrapped silence
to this one voice, which becomes
larger than one voice in a way.
That feels like creative.
Like it's making a world happen.
>> Robert Haas: And
there isn't that --
I mean, the thing to me is poets
begin with the kind of love
of the radiance of language.
I was thinking about the
power of your poem was
to say things --
saying a thing plainly.
You have to fall in love
with being able to say,
it's late afternoon
and the sun is misty.
Just let it sit there at that
line, or whatever the line is.
The sheer magic of being able
to take our senses and turn it
into these musical [inaudible].
>> Anya Creightney:
That was beautiful.
I mean, there are -- we have
just a couple minutes left,
so I just want -- since
we're supposed to talking
about the making of poetry
here, maybe we can close
and you can say, what's
something that you listen for,
either when you're writing?
And we've talked about this
in so many ways, but for those
of us who are writing
poems in the room,
how to make themselves
attentive to either a line,
as you're describing
in the book, Bob.
You said one line led to
another and so on and so forth.
Or a poem itself.
And maybe that can be the --
>> Tracy K. Smith: Okay.
>> Anya Creightney: --
the parting advice to
those in the audience.
>> Tracy K. Smith: I'm in town
with my eight year old daughter
and yesterday we went to
the Aaron Space Museum
and did a virtual
reality simulation
of going into a wormhole.
And I was thinking, that's
what we're trying to do in art.
We're trying to cover
these impossible distances
with like single words.
And I think that I get
excited when I see that happen.
I think metaphor
is the wormhole.
But sometimes metaphor
can live in a single word,
it can live in a verb chosen
from the animal kingdom
that's actually in service of,
you know, describing a
human or child or anything.
You're covering this
amazing distance,
even while you're
going somewhere else.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah.
>> Tracy K. Smith: And I get
excited when poems can do
that kind of succinctly, yet
robustly at the same time.
>> Anya Creightney:
Time machine.
Bob.
>> Robert Haas: I think
everybody is different
that way, but there are types.
Somebody said that the two kinds
of poets are oxen
and lions [laughter].
That they oxen put on the
harness and they pull every day.
>> Anya Creightney: Yeah?
>> Robert Haas: And the
lions sit around for a week
and then pounce [laughter].
And I think I've been
both at different times.
I'm definitely an oxen
where it comes to prose.
I have to pull.
And I tend to -- poets get
asked this a lot, you know,
how do you write poems?
And the answer, of course,
is we don't have the
faintest idea [laughter].
>> Anya Creightney: Right.
Right.
>> Robert Haas: But it certainly
begins for me with music.
With the disturbance into music,
of a phrase, of whatever kind
of phrase that suddenly
sounds like an entry -- yes?
>> Tracy K. Smith: Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
>> Robert Haas: An entry, yeah.
>> Anya Creightney: Well, I
think we can all relate to that.
Well, it's been an absolute
pleasure to talk to you both.
Our time is up already.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]